MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm Mano Marks.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Maps API team.
I'm happy to announce the latest
version of the Google Maps SDK
for iOS version 1.7.
In 1.7, we introduce
two new features--
gradient polylines and
structured reverse geocoding.
Let's start with
gradient polylines.
Gradient polylines allow you
to fill different segments
of a polyline with
different colors.
This is a useful feature
for data visualization.
You can use different colors
to show different variables,
like, say, elevation.
It's also useful for things
like routing-- for instance,
to indicate different
speed limits along a route.
What you see here is the
gradient polylines demo
from the SDK demos project
that comes with the SDK.
This example uses
gradient polylines
to show the elevation
of a walking
track on the coast of Italy.
The green part of the line
represents the highest
altitude, and then graduates
towards orange to red,
representing the lowest
altitude in the center.
The code is pretty simple.
Take a look at the
documentation and the demos
that come with the SDK download.
Now, let's look at
structured reverse geocoding.
Since we released the
Google Maps SDK in 2012,
we've had reverse
geocoding, which
takes a latitude longitude
pair and returns an address.
This is useful for
getting an address
of someone's current
location or the place
that they tap on a map.
In the past, a reverse
geocoder, GMS Geocoder,
has responded to a
latitude longitude request
with the address as
a formatted string.
With structured
reverse geocoding,
we return an address
object with properties
that allow you to easily
access its component parts.
In this demo, which also
comes with the SDK demos,
you can see if I
do a long press,
I get detailed information about
the locality-- in this case,
Sydney-- the administrative
area-- New South Wales--
and the country-- Australia.
In addition to
these two features,
1.7 includes some bug fixes.
So to see a complete list
of what's included in 1.7,
check out the release notes.
And as always, we're really
excited to hear your experience
using the SDK.
Please leave comments here
or on our Google+ page.
And as always, if
you need any help,
go over to Stack Overflow.
Our support page has all
the tags that you need.